in the coming weeks and months ahead
you're gonna hear a lot more
announcement is happening on this site
about new users new activities and
things that will bring vitality to the
site in its neighborhood and we're here
today to welcome those new neighbors to
generate new economies and to look ahead
to the rebirth of this place this site
has been vacant for twenty plus years
and for the neighborhood when you
constantly heard oh we're coming this is
happening this is happening and nothing
was really happening we turn the
momentum we have new storefronts we have
a new library we have a new school and
then you get announcements on this site
knowing that hey something's gonna
happen and it's not just four or five
people it's for our entire community
there's so much that I have learned in
this community ESMA green means a lot in
our vision going forward there's a lot
of excitement about what could be in
Hazelwood so we want to make sure that
the people who have lived here for years
are able to stay here and benefit from
all development icons I want to see
every person being able to access the
absolute highest level of education so
that they can compete around the world
this community is an opportunity to
create very positive development
experience
now finally some of those plans have an
opportunity to come to fruition when
you're looking at a new site with all
types of jobs that are going to be
happening we have to ensure the
Hazelwood residents have not only a
snake at the table but also have a job
the conversation that we've had from the
very beginning is that the Hazelwood
green site not be isolated from hazal
with a be integrated
I want Hazelwood to be
world-class community we're not saying
this is the site and that's neighborhood
no this is all blended together and
everybody in the neighborhood is welcome
down here and every business down here
is welcome in the neighborhood
[Music]